yeah hello welcome to this broadcast at
least the software tells me I'm live as
usual I like a small confirmation from
the chat that I'm indeed life because
sometimes it one doesn't tell you the
truth and since your life but you're not
okay let's get going yeah I have to
admit that currently in Germany we have
terribly hot temperatures and yeah if
you like my brain melted down today so
let's see what we can do and I think
fitting to that I'm going to do
something different today going to play
a little bit of three minutes yes and
I'm playing some crazy openings yeah
play gambits and wild stuff and see what
happens yeah thanks for confirming that
I'm live yeah someone says that my book
wasn't available in the u.s. until July
thirty-first hmm yeah maybe maybe this
light is available now I'm not totally
sure so we get to the Sicilian here I
don't need to do anything special to be
to be crazy maybe I can take with the
Queen and see what happens here mmhmm
yeah just develop him playing some I am
here from from Argentina I have to be
aware that it's three minutes that's
really important I'm really playing five
minute all the time and it can be
irritating can we see in Evans gambit
hmm I can try but I would mostly play
the Kings gambit if he goes you 45 no
ponens so not sure if we get the ovens
okay
I don't know something like 90 force
what they normally do and then play with
f 3 and so on so let's let's get going
f3 g4 and so on just move stuff forward
have 3g for next and yeah I don't know
thats it's rather slow what he's doing
taking ng5 not sure let's let's go King
do you want I think I have that time
available a nice little point is that if
he goes d5 i have e 5 Queenie 5 Bishop
f4 trapping the Queen just a neat little
trick so d5 is just bad here jam I'm a
bit ahead on the clock that's good i
think i'm going to go maybe nigeria and
then okay it's an interesting move well
i don't want to take so I'm we're
trading him giving him the open foul I
think it's no no good so I'm taking now
for g5 yeah my score with the Latvian
gambit it's not that bad yeah I know
people and some are don't turn yeah they
don't know how to play against that it
seems so I'm just pushing my pawns
forward and claim that I'm quicker here
with my advance probably i'm right with
that assumption while we takes it okay
i'm really close to playing f 6 cm okay
night f4 495 maybe all right let's start
with that it should be should be good
so night and for one night five night at
five g6 hmm all looks rather dangerous
for him I mean maybe just take a night
f5 okay be three be three years is
coming it is coming and not so clear
what I do against it
maybe that wasn't so great b3 is
dangerous it's a bit weird I know but I
really couldn't figure out something
great always playing well he's playing
well who not good not good at all that
doesn't look good all of the sudden is a
tech got so dangerous what did I do
wrong I don't know it looked very nice
there's a question of am planning to
cover any games that i recently played
in poland on my channel i do but i
couldn't yet really um yeah look look at
them properly in analysis didn't have
the time I'm really am busy quite a bit
with sending out copies of my book I had
this offer the people can offer the book
I can order the book from me with a with
a signature signature and it was very
popular was very popular so on that that
was quite quite a bit of work yeah look
III is around the corner
I have no move I have no movie and wow
that's really amazing I think I had a
very good position but it didn't work
out probably taking on g7 was bad
now ok let's resign it on time loss ok
that wasn't a good start but I'm used to
that um yeah some of those I need to
correct my green scaly right yeah not
during the broadcast do you think that
do I think that chessbase is essential
for players over 2,000 or even below I
don't know it's a it's a it's a good
thing it's a good thing to have but it's
not it's not necessary let's say but
once you get get above that level it's
definitely useful to have a good
database so um already we have a crazy
position he sacrificed a piece and
that's not a correct sacrifice but it is
somewhat tricky to play in blitz I have
some experience with it so let's see
just do five here or no idea dicho what
d 6 i can go d 6 cm it's nothing wrong
with it ready ok tix with the bond ok we
should be six or I can also just develop
that's probably a good idea so yeah
peace out four nights is seven so let's
get out of that I'm not in huge trouble
on the light square so King f7 is a
playable move and what I really have to
do is I have to speed up I am totally
used to five minutes chest and here
people can can three minutes chest you
can play any kind of nonsense and win on
time so I have to be aware that flagging
is their main main idea yet not playing
good chess so have to be have to be
quick here let's see if I can get rid of
that noise would be nice
so um yeah that's a question why why why
I wrote a book because it's not a good
business decision yeah it's not very
lucrative too wide a book but I always I
mean I'm a fan of chess books always
been and for years I thought okay I
really would like to have that
experience to ride one so I just thought
let's do it and I didn't think so much
about yeah considerations like how much
money does it pay or whatever I just
wanted to have it done and I think it
was a good experience it's not so likely
that I'm that I'm writing a new book
anytime soon but it's it was a good
experience okay that's two that's two
pieces and that will be enough okay so
next game what happened to my bookshelf
yeah in the in the broadcast here i'm
using a green screen now so we don't see
the books anymore um in the preview
video you still have seen books but not
as many as before the reason is that i
have tidied up my bookshelf i'm selling
tons of books and i will tell theo big
older opening books mostly as a question
do I plan to watch the upcoming movie
pawn sacrifice um I'll think about it oh
I played the trumpet ski I didn't want
to I wanted to play crazy openings
that's not really crazy but maybe we get
a sharp position anyway with F for later
let's go for that oh it's giving me the
center yeah that's nice
let's push f4 yeah just boring openings
the funny suggestion for my channel yeah
that's my usual mo play boring openings
well okay boring this may be a bit much
I'm still playing far more exciting
openings and let's say my nemesis mr.
legis but still I'm tend to be more
under on the solid side okay let's
activate that bishop you might get in no
I have an idea of six whenever he moves
his night down it's an option at least
um so other question what is the last
time I had a cigarette um that's a funny
question a real tobacco cigarette that
was november two thousand eleven so bent
benoa i did the the e-cigarette for a
while but also not for two and a half
years so night f4 looks good right going
towards the light squares yeah funny
opening challenge one week trying to
play like Vegas I don't know if it is so
fun to watch
yeah I haven't played them in a while
that's true maybe is it's not playing
that much at the moment it seems yeah ma
blitz gains games while smoking a
legendary thanks yeah I don't know
legendary is probably taking it a bit
far but they certainly are somewhat
unique it feels very weird nowadays to
to watch that and hear that the constant
lighting of new cigarettes but yeah I'm
glad that this this is behind me ok so I
jumped into his sixth year with the
night that looks interesting but yeah
still difficult to play this position so
ok I'll he he will mosey playing I don't
get it let me take him Syria 97 maybe as
dad yeah Blackmon Dima gambit do I have
any tips for building an opening
repertoire hmm I guess so but it's a bit
difficult in the context of this this
show I can try to answer specific
questions like yeah well what is a good
line versus this in that but it's
difficult to do a general kind of
opening yeah general opening advice
and the question if my chest has changed
after giving up smoking I don't know 11
clear difference is that you don't yeah
you don't leave the board as much for
going to smoke so on that that's a good
thing and your general fitness level
certainly is better but I'm not I'm not
so sure it should help but I can't
really say I recognize something very
specific yeah he just grabbed on be too
well that's a greedy customer that guy
but probably probably a good decision I
don't really know how to play here it
looks dangerous for me I between over
know where Luke is hanging oh yeah he
cannot take only six now because of that
pin but that it's all a bit shaky that
pond seems dangerous but I don't really
see how to support it properly Queenie
once 93 not good yeah it doesn't look
good what can I say he's giving the
check hmm yeah maybe that's even better
then what I what I had thought is
allowing that check here maybe it okay
night f2 but I can I just got queen d
one as well yeah anyway I have to play
move nine seconds to Queen D one arrow
key one
Queen takes h6 is made but that's
unlikely to happen unfortunately you saw
that
man I have to it's good night up to okay
that didn't work out so off to the next
game it's the killer so silly and a good
book despite being written by a man who
doesn't even have a feeder rating um
yeah it is a good book yeah I think the
author since law is a 2,100 player I
mean notice if you have a good general a
good general chess education with that
kind of level it's okay you can use
engines and you're very very diligent
worker you can produce a produce a very
good book even at that level so didn't
didn't start so well here come on give
me a new game yeah in the three-minute
pool
there's a question but submit what what
the moon is the webcam a PNG or
something I don't understand okay I'm
playing the Latvian against them feed a
master here from Finland yeah so this is
the Latvian and this disguise playing
one of the good lines against it after
which black just has a terrible position
it's easy to easy to refute this opening
but people have not done that before in
the streams but this guy is playing one
of the good lines and I really have no
idea to be honest how to even get
something like halfway playable position
85 it looks terrible I can just take
that actually what a bad opening you
take these three Bishop d3 babe like
it's lost yeah yeah the Latvian is just
just completely completely incorrect
opening it's absolutely not playable ok
so that's what I get for playing such
rubbish yeah I'm what like two points
down for no compensation that's great
what is this he allows me to take on g2
but he's got an ID f4 check but I can
take here right what's the big deal a ok
that's a check but that's just a check
hmm that's not so bad actually I mean
I'm a porn down and everything but it's
not not the end of the world really
queen h5 okay Queen a forward Jussi play
like night c4 or something the Queen
doesn't have many squares you are not c4
probably that is probably working yeah
where where do I go with that bloody
Queen here what a bad opening ever
mackade it's not it's not lost yet just
is just bad so maybe we can still fight
somehow before that's a weird move ok
jump jump right in so maybe here that's
something something to get developed
quickly ok move that Queen away hmm
isn't there some kind of tactic here I
mean it looks kind of strange here for
him
it's got Bishop e2 in the mix as strange
as it looks I don't I don't really see
anything great it stays a bad position I
don't know I have to move it's just bad
so what is he doing now night c4 or
something Jeff I don't really know what
to play against Ted Queen a fire phone
just bad the worst thing is I'm not
threatening anything mean not in the
slightest we took it okay i mean i can i
can take have to him play that position
upon down hmm cannot check there yeah
i'm just playing two pawns down here and
they have no time that's great yeah that
really happens if you play the latvian
end the other guy it's not totally brain
dead then you just smash you
yeah it's just two points and absolutely
zero compensation 93 maybe I can
irritate them a little bit there with
Luke coming to eat two or something not
really I can take here though okay
didn't play it well but it's still
sufficient
got five seconds that's bad I cannot
really pre-move completely Wow what is
it doing here okay maybe I can promote
the a pond just got three seconds ah
laddie I should play rook a seven okay
that was there was some chances actually
I go route 87 but ok all you know this
opening is just too bad yeah it is just
too bad what can you do the Latvian is
just unplayable if the SS said if the
opponent is not totally brain dead okay
so next game it doesn't work out too
well right I'm losing here I now I get a
good opponent actually going master Kuro
to laugh that's the 2600 player let's do
something with their form can I do
something in the style of the of the
hardest court the Grand Prix attack yep
something like that
yep try to get him get this Bishop to d7
yeah do you go a five now is that too
early might be to earlier I'm trying to
get the Queen over to h4 okay
okay some starting out with quick
pressure there on the on the queenside
yeah maybe I can check with the pawn
that too bad don't know it doesn't look
so bad let's put that on the side and
Paul is a bit under pressure the c3
permit I don't know he cannot really
increase the pressure that much hmm i
don't think that this is bad looks kind
of okay and at least i'm not two pounds
pawns down like in the latvian where you
lose immediately that's a big advantage
in comparison seeking de fryer probably
not so nice attacking that pony is
playing well it's a really good place
two thousand six hundred grand master so
not your average GM even so Bishop
deform or something like that or Bishop
h4 is taking on a three let's go here
and trade that
ok scrubbing that porn ok I can go here
and go from them that's not enough
compensation but it's still kind of
interesting
so how to go from here my night is not
playing it's really a problem it should
do something but also this pawn is under
constant pressure maybe this rook f4
night h3 495 ok so I'm playing it better
opening up the long diagonal down nice
is playing well mmm but it wasn't really
necessary but it's it's not a problem of
course no mistake I mean yup and that's
the problem
I cannot move my knight simply
yeah those plants haha those bones are a
bit much not even threatening Queen h7
here unfortunately but it's still
reacting us somehow to it yeah I mean it
just totally lost so check him here hmm
it's not really I mean you can just take
with the porn i think was 96 a move okay
it's not playing that Kim I my bishop is
hanging but
okay anyway I'm not only file anymore
it's not not really threatening anything
rookie one next maybe but as I said it's
not really it's not any serious threat
going on no I wanted to play the night
there a stupid there was a mouse slip
really not saying that it would have
made any difference but it would have
been far more interesting of course ok
check it's no check unfortunately no I
played it played it well he may be
allowed me some some tricks but it
didn't end when he didn't really work
out ok so let's see d for what can I do
against d for this kind of aggressive
some Ben Oni maybe was some Kings Indian
it doesn't really work out this idea of
playing somewhat loose openings usually
I don't do too badly them so I've got a
classical Kings Indian here everyone
well
why don't people went by people don't
play the main line that that's
interesting at least now not the
Budapest gambit that just totally
rubbish opening it's not even aggressive
black just has a passive bad position
well let's say so in Seoul position so
let's try to confuse them a little bit
cannot take you tonight your three check
but a 12 why not h6 actually where would
you've gone on 93 was also possible I'm
playing badly here come on let's play
let's play good chess at least a little
bit ah so you can check here I can check
their first let's take them
so I'm taking their 93 has Knight f6
that's not good so let's develop now
that's a good position I think there's a
question how long does it take to get
good opponents in the 25-minute poor
it's an interesting question I don't
know I hope it doesn't take so long the
mismatches that the moment I but I bit a
bit crazy okay can I check here I guess
hmm yeah but h6 where do you go to e7 or
what is the point
that's it's totally weird yeah why is
not losing that Bishop Bishop e7 hmm not
quite sure I can check I also do this
and Bishop you three maybe that's the
way to do it now I guess so
so let's attack that Bishop and I don't
know where is he going with that to have
six up later look I've fade and then
it's got 96 it's kind of crazy okay
let's keep it simple take a second pause
and go from there
yeah opposite colored bishops but I have
a good good initiative there so that
looks pretty good now i can push my
pawns it's nice to have some extra pawns
i resigned ok so let's go for the next
game immediately the black mud dima
gambit is suggested hmm i can try it's
not as bad as the latvian
that's a question about my book why did
I go with the bogo I'll answer that
after this game this is when masters
veered osorio that's also 26 player I'm
trying the black madam a gambit against
him but it's it's not the kind of
opening to beat 2600 GMS with normally
but let's see i don't know it seems that
he at least it's not dashing out moves
immediately I thought this is the way
you play this with with g4 and stuff
maybe not
disqus move I have no idea it just feels
like I'm a porn down okay yam
threatening night f7 at least playing
for super cheap tricks yeah i can take
b7 now is that right let's take it so
maybe i should keep that pin and effect
to keep him somewhat irritated them okay
night be late no that means hahaha okay
but i have Quincy aid at the end that
maybe I mean okay that wasn't it wasn't
intended of course but maybe it's kind
of still kind of interesting Hey look
the seven checkmate is the thread maybe
you can just take with the night yeah
that's that's really probably true I
don't have I don't have anything here
that's unfortunate it was fun that I had
this idea at all
maybe this roof I don't know says some
kind of idea so i can go king of
saronite it will it will hold amongst
others and he probably has other moves
but King f7 looks pretty safe actually
maybe yes yeah yes something brutal for
rook takes II to Queen here
yeah Kim I have to do that I guess and
see from here still that that made
Quincy tune
and he has 93 as well yeah just not
working just its loss you defended that
well yeah probably a couple of things
win now the simplest is still King f7
you know now I can resign I don't even
have a check so that didn't work out so
um so I'm a question about that book
yeah i'm doing i'm going with the bogo
in the book because it leads to dark
squared strategies while the Queen's
engine is a light squared opening and it
was the plan to have somewhat common
themes in the book so it it was pretty
much clear that I would go for the Bogle
and not the Queen zinian that doesn't
mean that the Queen's engine is bad or
anything it's just totally fine but it
just didn't fit the the general idea of
that of that repertoire book so playing
Z loco yeah it's kind of I mean I'm
always sitting in that strategically bad
positions but I play those obliques it's
sometimes it's a bit tiresome and the
thing is if you play opening some like
levels gambit so I mean the gambits are
sometimes just objective rubbish but if
you play something like like this ya
like em then the learning good Dutch
it's really paramount that you know what
you're doing and I'm kind of inventing
things as I go along and sometimes
that's simply not enough so it takes I
can't eat with the night
yeah maybe this is not so bad but not a
huge fan of this position well this is
rook there are only three it looks nice
but also block said bishop so I might be
okay yeah actually I wonder if night
before as a move takes Bishop Jake's end
up sitting on f 2 Queen yet is a strange
movie app it is the main line so it's
not it's pretty pretty established I
don't know if that was a good idea can I
go Bishop g4 here is that bad rook f7
Bishop e2 might be might be an idea
right
sometimes it something someone is saying
um I think sometimes you don't play the
gambit in the gambit spirit yeah there's
no nothing is this is this is sorry guys
the opening some ropings are rubbish
it's not about spirit or whatever it's
just total trash and you just worse you
can play whatever you want if the other
guy plays it well you're going to get
killed this is for example happening
with the Latvian the black madam a
gambit is also total rubbish yeah the
Dutch the Dutch is ok it's but it's
something that you also need to know
well it's it's it's a it's a good
opening if you specialize in it and
invest some time not sure if it is a
great idea to play the Dutch if you yeah
once just want a secondary opening or
whatever it's something that you really
need to know to play well because you
you take some strategic risk just
typically the earth porn simply moved
very early on and this means that you
sometimes suffer from weaknesses and so
on so can I take on can I take on a to
rook takes rook team on Bishop f1 Bishop
c4 hmm it's not so convincing I can't
think I should go just go back here but
where yeah maybe all the way you cannot
take be seven anyway for Ruby one what's
a good opening that you don't need to
know lots of sharp lines hmm yeah I mean
so that's a very that's a very white
white question let's say um with white
with black and so on you are you can go
for especially if you are wide you can
go for these system types approaches
where you play am basically the same
thing regardless what the other side is
doing like the London system or
something like that
the drawback is it's normally not that
exciting um I really recommend to stay
within normal bounds of theoretical main
lines you can still vary a bit to make
it job to do not play that the total
main line but still play something that
is kind of um yeah kind of established
as being good so what happens here I
wanted to go rookie seven which I cannot
play that's bad oh I didn't have to
admit I didn't look that much because of
the time situation I was thinking that
probably i'm going to win on time c3 or
something they are Kim don't have to be
just just when our time is good um so um
do you think any question yeah with
black you're playing something that is
not so much theory it depends on what
kind of position you like Oh again okay
let's play the Dutch again for example a
good auditive Lee good opening let's say
against efore if you wander wander an
idea that it's relatively little in
terms of knowledge there are some lines
in the Scandinavian defense that for
example are pretty pretty simple to play
yeah there are lines like them you know
I think he has g6 now right yeah yes I
know then I play that stuff myself
actually sometimes and this is a pretty
rubbish position again but okay maybe I
can confide yeah the Scandinavian for
example it's not not such a bad choice
for them really in terms of yeah what
what what what do you need to know and
how good
it is a pretty good deal ah what a bad
position yeah it's not really a I really
I really bungled up that opening here ah
who do I can I get some kind of position
yeah it's drifted already very difficult
hmm night f1 Jesus amazing yeah as I
said you can play such a system kind of
opening but it won't it's not it's not
very entertaining and it's not the
greatest learning to let's say and some
some other openings you will definitely
learn more Wow amazing
it's not even playing it the best
possible way but it is totally
sufficient 96 check now is a threat to
totally in shambles him again I g6 very
much what a disaster okay I know I won't
do that ever again this kind of openings
have a book the book ever read the book
Bobby Fischer revisited I don't even
know that what is that aside a new book
I don't know it sorry
yeah I'd well i'm not that much
interested in stuff about Fisher anymore
I mean it it's like the games hmm I
don't know I studied the games when I
was a kid all of them really all and I
don't know if I'm I'm so if it would
yeah I mean I don't know if a new book
what would add something to that uh yeah
great 96 cannot move my bishop it simple
most impossible here to make a move
it's an amazingly bad position ah yeah
yeah anyway what a rubbish position Wow
what are my thoughts about Watson's play
the French fourth edition hmm I don't
know that they are basically all good
those books he always invests lots of
effort and it's there there are well
researched so for for French oh um
aficionados you should probably get
Watson's books that's a weird position
that was from a French defence that's it
that's a crazy position it looks like a
really good version of the Kings gambit
drats keys end game manual yeah that's
that's the modern the modern classic for
in gameplay really every serious chess
player has that book I think and I mean
it's really um if you want a good end
game book that's on on on a high level
let's say two rats kisses basically the
only one that you that you need I always
recommend this book by castle stay a VR
Garcia for for somewhat simpler and
games and if you want the the
complicated stuff then you go with the
ad game manual and your you will be fine
don't need anything more so what is this
I'm head on the clock that sets the
first thing to note if I gunite age 5
i'm close to threatening cringey 6 after
cancelling maybe maybe i can get that in
but he has Queen takes e4 unfortunately
so it's not a direct idea do i watch
other people streams um hmm not that
much simply due to lack of time not that
they are bad or anything is just that I
don't know I don't know when Grandmaster
preparation endgame book yeah that
that's a good one by the our guide but
that's very high level 44 let's say
master players if you if you are if you
don't feel confident let's say in basic
endings you should just get the div a
book and find a fine so what about this
how do I get this going here let's play
you five and try to open it up it's
going there I can take on f7 mm-hmm
we'll just night except for maybe I know
maybe that so that's a simple situation
I could play the first board for
liechtenstein in the Olympiad yeah maybe
I could have not sure what what players
they have so that looks kind of nice
let's cover that and it's equal material
actually yeah that that is true
that is true maybe oops sorry hey maybe
here yeah it's not it's it's about equal
this position I guess he's still fairly
solid playing planning f6 maybe let's
get the king near no that's the idea not
very difficult but I still didn't didn't
spot it that's probably still equal this
position yeah that's equal look F 2
rupee 5 rook takes f7 good rock gt5 or
anything I don't know that's slow draw
so e6 or not it's probably not the the
best possible way to go let's just play
a normal move I mean rookie evade is
something that you can play of course
but it won't help you to win the game so
maybe win a little bit of space it is
still very dry mmm this one
it's probably a draw here maybe I can go
to e6 or something I ads it's still at
all quite clearly so Jim it's hard to do
something else checks me
I'm slow here what am i doing you
I was sick but I had said I was in pre
move mode I have to play more with free
moves kind of rusty here so um there's a
question let's say if i ever met german
food master Stein baha that's some some
strange question I actually have played
this guy I have played against mr. Stein
Baja and won the game in two thousand
one or two thousand two I think in a
pretty important game oh wow now we get
now we get a political questions I am
not quite sure if I should answer them
I'm still have a new game requests out I
hope the stream is entertaining anyway
um even though I'm not playing very well
in order for me to play a bit better
maybe you should do this to the stream
much earlier you have an opinion on that
question it's about legalizing of um
yeah what is what is the wheat yeah I
guess that's a question do I play chess
for a living no i don't i'm proud too
bad for that but I teach chest and I
think this is a different thing um and I
do I write the books and stuff like that
I play against drop stone very high
rated I am let's see was that David
David para v on I don't know that guy
honey so we got a fairly normal position
at the end of it oh he wants to win that
pawn what a greedy greedy man no no he
doesn't take it but that makes Queen f6
look a little bit dubious in my book so
let's go h4 h5 no beating around the
bush now that porn is a bit weak but
can't have it all no I never have played
someone over the board where I thought
he was cheating really never not not
even close so well it's it's a good move
huh that is a good move Bishop f5 is in
the mix doesn't look good quite an
awkward pin
it's okay Bishop f5 is something that I
might be able to play as well I will
take with the rook funny how he moves
I don't see a good reply to that to be
perfectly honest you can just grab a
pawn if he likes maybe you'll do that
but I my baby rock the eight ish is
stronger so getting back here and I know
you can take f2 now at the end of that
line that is so that's better yeah very
well played by my opponent it's very
very convincing way to continue that
game
Jim their part is very very very strong
maybe I can get Ruby seven but the
problem is even if I pick up those
points you take the H porn and it's just
a bit quicker so not good
yeah I mean it's possible that i played
against someone who cheated I don't
think that's it's impossible but I
really never had this this strong notion
that it is happening not really yeah
okay that's that's not that's not going
to work out let's get one more game to
try to finish on a high note yeah there
are many cheetahs around nowadays it's a
common it's a very sad but very common
subject nowadays unfortunately I really
never played one I mean online quite
obviously it happens quite a bit because
it's so so easy to do but at least the
very obvious cheetahs I getting caught
now quite reliably I think um one issue
surprisingly enough is a thing with
online cheating is that I sometimes hear
that people say okay this isn't that guy
cheated against me and then I hastam
okay I did you complain yeah I mean did
you send that to the server so that they
bend the guy and then the answer is no
and I don't get that I mean they say
well yeah if he is been then there will
be other people and so on but you have
to bend the people and make sure that
they don't continue and this is really
essential have to bend them over and
over again and at one point they will
they will stop what they're doing ok so
I'm going with this again the sriman
that this is actually a good opening and
comparison to the Latvian so let's see
what Picasso is going to do here
Grandmaster Osorio
so I still cannot cancel which is a
common problem of course of those
openings where you move the f porn early
on but i'll try with a quick something
quick two is six here Bishop e6 okay I
cannot just go Bishop b6 because of them
because of my c7 porn okay he's playing
very aggressively here but
understandable decision taking avoids
probably more than risky so let's do
that preparing we should be six I think
I can take here with the Queen that that
shouldn't be so bad the end game is
quite quite okay I mean not great but
may be playable why you can't take
Bishop e3 might still be better for what
um the here's the here's a question
you're not allowed to swear here yeah in
some words are definitely band so be a
bit cautious there so what now Bishop to
have seven probably Jim be five is very
weakening but maybe I don't see how I
get my things developed maybe this one
but this should be six is still a lot of
move yeah not easy to play this position
bishop I can check him here then Bishop
e3
yeah but what else is there i don't have
any other square
yeah it seemed it seems crazy but I have
to do this for bit should be six next
getting developed somehow
wow really why is that working I don't
get it maybe it's just I'm just 22
weekend Queen g34 attacking here and
there okay okay maybe we should be 34
Queen g7 some claim wow wow yeah very
well played yeah he doesn't play me so
much online anymore but this guy was one
of the best online blitz players here in
the world some years ago and think it
still shows yeah I cannot cover g7
simply okay to kick that in okay so is
there any question the last couple of
lines there I don't think so there have
been some the deleted messages so be
cautious with your language okay i still
hope you enjoy to the broadcast I didn't
play it well okay I hope you join next
week when i'm returning to five minutes
chess and play a little bit more serious
openings to hook up to well this time ok
guys thanks for watching